So if we have problems
finding good people quickly somewhere,
we'll do a paidad or
something like that and say hey, we're looking for
new bakers here in Heidelberg,
but for the most part we haven't put
much into it yet  The topic of marketing is invested so
it's easy back then our founders
came up with a very good concept,
I think you can
say very clearly how they sewed, especially
for that time, there
are now
similarly good bakery concepts in all cities back then
that was unheard of  and and we
simply created this shopping experience
with the glass bakery
where you can really look in on
site with a cool design of the shops
and that just drew a warm
welcome to the OMR podcast today an
episode that I'm really curious about
because I walked past a branch
I thought okay, what is that
and then shortly afterwards by chance I
read an article about Time for
Bread, a new type of bakery chain and
I thought okay, we have to
understand that and we have never had
bakeries here in the podcast, today it starts
The managing director of Zeit für
Brot is very welcome Stefan
Heinrich hi Stefan hi thank you very much, you
are not the founder right away
but the company has
not been around that long yet how long has it been
around but the company has been around since
2009 so it is actually the one  The
original founder opened the first
shop in Frankfurt in the öderweg
back then, but he has
n't been with the company since 2018, then at
some point a Berlin
managing director joined in, then at some point it
was sold to private
equity and you were appointed
as managing director and probably also
involved in the company  like it's always like that,
no, not really, but
incentivized, incentivized, yes, long-term,
incentivized, exactly that if
one day there should be a sale of PR equity, I'm
already working towards that
somehow or an IPO
maybe like who knows whos, yes, then that's
fun for me  Fun exactly
and otherwise I am of course
incentivized by the appetite yes of course
of course so at the end we are talking about
a baker before we
get into exactly what the baker does differently
than others why you are now dying in times of
bakeries and such a
bakery chain with growth and PR
equity money is somehow presented very
briefly, you are a boy from
Duisburg and for a long time you were, so to speak, in
various industrial groups at
Bayersdorf at the Webergrill, yes, exactly,
and then you got to
know time for bread, yes, exactly.
So I've
actually had a relatively wild, wild journey  After
graduating, I studied political science
and then actually
decided to go into business and
started at Lidl. I
actually picked up a lot of things that
help me today for the whole topic of
standardization, which is what I call branch business, and
I'll tell you why we do  I do
n't like the word branches
and then I was at Bayersdorf in
various positions, then I was
at Webergrill and now at Zeit für
Brot and um how did the first contact
come about um yes I saw
an advertisement on LinkedIn for
the Chief Operating Officer at  at Time
for Bread and to be honest I did
n't think much of it, I just
thought, oh, it's a cool company.
I didn't realize that they already had several ledden. I knew that from
my time in Frankfurt. I
actually lived in the öderweg back then, around 2010
to  13
around the time I was working at Lidl
and then I saw that it was
time for bread to be a somewhat larger
company, they apparently
also exist in Berlin and I was in the
position at Weber grill at the time where, among other
things, I was involved with the Weber original
stores  and Weber Grill academies
and yes I thought about
everything that could be
exciting in terms of additional range
for the
shops yes I'm involved and
I had time for bread
because of the delivery of burgers and
baguettes okay and then we got to know each other there
K learned and then
of course I brought it up hey I
saw you were also looking for a COO
and
yes then the discussions came about
then I met the private equity
investors and that's how it
came about okay okay um what kind of
company are we talking about  So how many
falen are there today um so we
now have 13 locations just said we
don't like the word branch
the background is that
every shop works standalone and
is not really like a chain
but really every shop is a
neighborhood bakery but  We'll
definitely get to the
business model in a bit, maybe he's
selling something, so would it be fair or
would you feel addressed if
I said a bakery at all?
You're saying that's actually wrong, no, we
are, we are, even from my point of view,
we are  the original form of the bakery because
what we do is really bake, we
are not a baking shop but we are
really a bakery that bakes in the suburbs at the
location where we also sell in the
city center and from the dough
production, so really from the
raw material, flour, water, salt and so
on  final bread okay and what
sells a roll bread as well as
in how you know how exactly standard
bakery range we have a relatively
small range compared to
other bakeries so we have around
45 different items while other
bakeries have up to 100 different or
even more different ones  The article also
has a lot of seasonal changes,
of course, but not that much. We
sell bread, we sell rolls,
we sell sweet parts, so our
snails, cardamom buttons, chocolate and
so on, and how much more expensive it is at
your place than at the normal bakery. That
depends, of course  from what you call a
normal bakery
from what I know now when I
walk in to the RWE there is one in the cash register area I do
n't know in the raw area it's called
Döbbe I think that's where I grew up
in Hamburg it's often something like a baker's
boy or something like that so what's there  For
you, yes, I would estimate that
we are probably 10% 20% more expensive,
something in this size, how much does a
roll cost? A roll costs around
70 cents, okay, it also depends on what's in it,
no, if there
are walnuts in it  The raw materials are
normally 70 cents for a normal roll but now it costs
between 70 and 1.30
so up to 130 if there are nuts
and so on in it, okay and that's
only 20% more than at a bakery
that has that somewhere
Baked separately or or or and
that the branch simply brings in in the morning.
Yes, I think that's the
point with which you compare it. If you
go to the discount store, I don't know where
the rolls probably start
at 9 cents, somewhere between 9 and 20
cents  I would guess, um, that's
the price range for a roll
in a bakery,
um, but of course we compare ourselves
to other organic bakeries, you
always have to differentiate, so there are
a lot of different
bakery concepts on the market, and
we have organic farm products and with
them  I'm actually comparing us now
so we are we are
Bioland certified so you have um
in the organic sector you have controlled
organic cultivation so EU organic so to speak that's what it says
standard organic I'll say
now and then you have so-called
association products like demeta or Bioland
or  Naturland where you
join an association and have them
certify you again and they have even
higher
requirements for the products and what
is the pitch to the customer so
why should a customer pay more now
because of this organic farmware
or so it starts with it  In
principle, the topic of raw materials is
certainly a very important point, we
use very, very high-quality raw materials
in organic quality and then you have the
very important pitch part that is baked on site,
which is actually
the main ingredient because, as you
said before, it is  is a
lot of baked goods that are then baked at the location where they are
sold, if
at all if I just
deliver them crosswise, um and we manufacture
completely on site, which
means quality,
which
means shorter supply chains, so the
whole issue of sustainability
but it is simply
very, very good  The goods we produce
on site taste delicious then
definitely so I think, um,
our customers think so
too, or we notice that this is
valued, it actually makes
a difference in quality, so
this is really manufactured on site, um
whereby you  Of course,
you also have well-crafted goods that are then
manufactured in branch companies, so there
are some that are
industrially manufactured and then
simply baked, like all the
discounters, um, and there are
also central bakeries, especially in the organic and bioland sector
Their branches
where they only sell deliver and there
are concepts like ours,
but there aren't many that actually
produce locally, but
producing them locally has an influence on the
taste. Do you say that changes the
taste?  If you do, you get it
fresher, so I'll say with
us, if in doubt, you get it warm
from the oven
and there is 2 m between
the production site and the sales site
and that actually makes a
difference
but the normal customer
actually checks what the difference is between a
baking oven and a
real oven, so to speak, where everything is baked completely from the start. Um, I
think so
and you can definitely taste it if you
do a tasting now and
taste them against each other  There is
always the
need for you to
have other additives in it and so on and
that is all eliminated with us, so depending on
how you
produce it, for example if you produce it in larger
facilities in the central
bakery you have to artificially
add gluten to it  is a natural enzyme that
is already in the flour, but it has to be
added artificially and
we don't have to do that, so the fact that the
quality of a baked
item is as you
imagine it inevitably means
that you have to add something  and
so on, it is relatively difficult and rather
rare for you to actually have this quality when it comes to pager
tikeln blanks or dough pieces, i.e. deep
chilled or as blanks that are then
banked up on site,
okay, but nevertheless you are
obviously already targeting a wealthier
clientele
Something like that, we're talking
about price, even if it's now a
cent amount for the rolls,
at least 3 x 4, so between 20
cents and 80 cents it's a
factor of 3, at least no, yes,
I wouldn't
honestly say that  that we are
addressing a more affluent audience, I
believe that we are addressing an audience
that really values
very, very good bread
and sustainably produced bread made
from high-quality raw materials,
so not not wealthy per se, so
where is it, what are your locations?
If you now where are you in Berlin where
are you in Hamburg where are your
branches so we are in Hamburg
we are now in Ottensen and at the
eendorfer
Baum for example you have a slightly
different clientele everywhere maybe
you have locations of ours where you can
then  I actually have a somewhat more affluent
clientele, but I believe that they
are more of a gourmand and people
who
value very, very high organic quality.
In Berlin we are from Mitte to
Prenzlauerberg to Charlottenburg,
so we have five different
stores. Potzdam is in Frankfurt,
we are in three locations  So in the
train station district in Sachsenhausen and in
m in the Nordend, so really
residential areas but also residential areas
where there is a bit of frequency and do
you have problems if, so to speak, there is such a
bakery or a
discounter right next to you
then people come and  go by price or
tell you that we don't care at all
or we even consciously go where
other bakers are in order to somehow
convince them with our quality and
then take away a little bit of the customer.
No, honestly that's not the
strategy at all. We go where we do  and I think that
's the biggest challenge in our expansion strategy.
We're going where we manage
to open a location because we
have full production at the location, which
means we need a lot more space than
a normal bakery, um, we need electricity, we
need statics, so
it  It's very difficult to find a time for a
bread location where we
can open because we have such high
requirements, so it's much more
complicated than a restaurant because of
course we also have all the issues of
exhaust air over the roof and so on,
but also static electricity and so
on  For full production,
people tend to underestimate that, it really is
full production on site, which means that
the strategy is not to
sit down somewhere and say,
man, there are already other bakers or
there are a lot of buyers or something like that, of course
we look at frequency  Of course
we look at so-called sinus muscles,
who lives in the area, but it's
not just wealthy people, there
are a lot of people who
attach great importance to organic products, for example, so we're happy to sit
next to the organic supermarket,
for example, who he says here in the podcast
Somehow he's also observing this now
with the
somewhat difficult economic situation,
um many people who bought organic maybe a dozen
years ago in the boom times do
n't do that anymore. That's
also true, um you definitely have it
in the entire organic sector, so you can see
um  At the organic food
retailers, i.e. at the
organic supermarkets, you have a decline in
frequency. Basically, people are not
buying organic, um, less, the
shopping location has changed a bit,
that is, you have, for example, in the discount,
let's take Lidl, they also sell
Bioland, I think all of them  The work with
Naturland when we
talk about association goods you already have
a change that people buy more there,
which means people are
of course much more sensitive when it
comes to the price. Thank God we
don't notice it, because I believe that with us,
our customers  In fact, that's where we
save the least, so we really have
customers who, atypical for Germans,
at least historically,
spend a lot of their income on high-quality food and simply
value it and I think that
actually makes the difference, so
I don't think that we do  We're often said to be a chic
Micki baker,
that we only
appeal to high-priced or price-insensitive customers. I don't think that's the
case and we see that too, so we
really have from to all people from
students who traditionally at least
not like that  don't have that much money,
or at least I did
n't have that much money as a student, but they
really care about the fact that it's Bioware
and Bioland even and,
above all, that it just tastes good
and is good in the normal branch
like many customers  Do you have
around 1000 okay 1000 customers a day, that means the
shopping cart is then I don't know what 5
6 € yes okay that means an F makes
5 6000 € in sales a day, very
different so that's
a good one  Location on a good day
too but yes we definitely do
more than an average bakery
branch so simply because of the frequency
let me do a quick calculation 5000
what is the annual sum of the branch
as I said again from to but
with 2 million or something like that 2 million
Plus we are already satisfied and
then at the current size we do
n't know what h 15 branches or so 13
we have it is easy to calculate 2
million 20 30 million so somewhere
between 30 and something like 30 sales I
yes we actually do then
The additional pillar is our
delivery customer business,
for example we supply a natura Denz butni here in
Hamburg quickly and all in all
we make around 40 million in sales
okay and but growth is probably already
planned now I can imagine
private equity there has to be a
chart somewhere  give where it says how to
reach 100 million
yes when should that be the case should that be
achieved
m that to be
honest we won't be
put under much pressure of course we
want to grow we also want to grow together
we
also work very, very closely together
and and  update and it is constantly
more important that we grow well and
sensibly, that is, what I
just said, the complexity of
locations, we talk about it very, very
often, so the goal is
that we open three to four new locations
per year in Germany  um and
and we've managed to do that so far
and we also have locations in
the pipeline for the future, but it's
definitely the case
that we want to grow healthily, so the
SP so if there's something
at the large bakeries, so to speak,
I understand that it will somehow  centrally
produced then there is logistics,
the stand is supplied
and what do you probably do? Finding
staff isn't that
easy, I imagine the brand, what else
does the stand do?
with all the challenges
that I just mentioned and then the
next challenge is definitely
the skilled workers because we
and that's why I don't like to say chain
or branch because each location
is really a small microcosm that
works relatively independently,
we need them everywhere
Location so a relatively high number
compared to classic, let's say,
branch bakeries that
work with central production, we need a
relatively high number of skilled workers, which
means that
a large number of well-trained bakers work at each location, master
bakers, journeyman bakers,
trainees in sales, of course, the
same, um, so that  Every location
is really a microcosm and we
have a very, very high requirement for skilled workers and you can still find
a lot of young people who
want to become bakers,
basically not, so that's
definitely a huge topic, um for us it's
definitely one of them too  One of
the biggest issues we're
dealing with at the moment is
that I think we
offer things for young people. You can
work with us day and night,
I say, either day
or night. Many bakers want to, for example  I'm
happy to work at night, there's tax
and social security-free surcharges,
um, but others might
only want to work during the day, depending on how you
live your life and so
on, um and we can
offer everything, so we can say you if
someone says they want a week
Work at night for a week, um, then
we can offer that. We can say that
if someone says they only want to work during the day,
then we offer that. If someone
says they only want to work at night,
we can also offer that. So we have
a relatively high level of flexibility and then
you have to  Of course, take into account that
our locations are in, um,
inner city locations, which means it's
easier to get there, there are perhaps
prestige locations here and there now that are
different than if you have a central bakery
that produces somewhere in a green field
on a green bese or in an
industrial area in a hall
is simply a different
workplace then of course we have
benefits like that you get free meals from us
so you can
eat as much as you want, I say
from what we sell um and then the
usual other benefits ne from a
public person but what  hot
actually people apply to
you so that means it's still like that you
somehow put up an ad
or don't know and then people come and
say hey I'm interested in
getting trained or or I'm
crazy I want to start with you
fortunately that's current
largely as I said, we
also have to recruit, so
we put a lot of attention
and ultimately money into it so that
we can find good people, but it's
definitely definitely the case that we're currently
fortunate that it's
continuing like this that we're under  The bakers are
still
very better than other bakeries, no,
I don't think so, so we pay well,
which is what you pay as a baker, if you say a
baker with 5 years of experience,
it goes from to to, so you're at
€17-18 for an hour  Yes, and hey, what
kind of annual salary usually comes
out of 170 hours, so I would have to
calculate it myself, okay, what you
shouldn't forget are
all these surcharges for
Saturday work for Sunday work, we
really have 24 hours at some locations
Open 7 days a week and
then shift work, and then that's why
you can't say that in general terms. You
have a lot about surcharges and
also surcharge logic, holidays, Sundays
and so on, okay and
of course you still have people who
just work at the counter  In a way, they
work from
normal temporary workers to from to so
many students but also
the work then more part-time but
also full-time employees
who then I would say also classic
bakery specialists sometimes so
really from to there we don't have any
specific requirements either  It just has to
be fun for food
and say, when you go into the store,
I think that's
always the best thing for me too because people have
fun selling somewhere, have fun with the
product, above all, so
luckily we can still do that
to convey to our our new
people okay and what is the
biggest cost factor for you is it the
salaries or rather the rent or the
raw materials what what costs money so the
three things that you say are
certainly the the biggest factors the
biggest  The cost factor is by far the
personnel costs -
I think it's always like that in a company like this -
raw materials but in
second place and then in third
place are the rents and if
a branch like this is doing well then you ca
n't make a 20% margin on it
That would be nice,
yes, in the sense of that's that's
roughly what you're hoping for, so 2
million provides about €4,000
the contribution yes, yes, okay and if you
now extrapolate that to the entire
company then you probably still have a
little bit left  The costs for your
head office with 14 sales let me
now give a quick estimate, that's
about
8 million um that's
left over for now, but then all your
costs come from in the branch, how many
people do you have in the branch office
in the head office  then there at the
headquarters
so we don't have a central office
but it's decentralized we have
people sitting in Frankfurt Hamburg people
sitting in Berlin people sitting there because of the fact
that through this
shop of the decentralized of course
relatively high intensity of support
is also necessary ne so V  HR Business Partner
as they now call it on site
but also regional management
and so on Key Account Managers who
look after our B2B people All in all
we have around 35 people who
manage centrally okay that's blasting then
I'd say it again  Million or something like that but then
you can or maybe one and a half
but then you can somehow 2 million
not 3 million yes so our EBIT there
is still a little more than 2
million so no no I now had
the burden from the from the from
the  35 heads, I was
just now thinking about what they were like. To be
honest, I can't tell you
exactly,
so in the end you'll make 5 6
million, a rough order of 5
6 million is enough and of course if you
grow now then you can develop
100 sales is of course significantly more
okay okay and S your brand is the more
important than time for bread is also
a say an unusual brand per se
like that you notice that people
say that I want to consciously work
on it that as  To be
honest, we haven't really built a brand so far. We actually
consciously invested in marketing in the
classic sense for the first time last year, in that we
now
have two people who don't work part-time on the topic, so far
it was somehow Instagram itself or something like
that was somehow done by H  sometimes
by regional management, sometimes by me,
sort of casually cared for um so we were
we were or we are
relatively proud of the fact that we
had to invest relatively little in it um which I
also think is really good so time for
bread has actually managed it over the last
10 years  largely
through the product quality and the
shopping experience to convince the customers.
Now
of course the more we grow the more
we have to keep ourselves busy when we
go to a new city now
we opened in Heidelberg this year
in potzam  We have opened a
second store in Hamburg, but we opened it in a
completely different corner of Hamburg
where people might not
know us that well, so we are
gradually starting to invest, which
means we are now more professional,
for example in social media marketing,
so we are using Instagram first
Line is much stronger than before but
now not so that we
somehow pay who knows how much, so if
we
have problems somewhere to
find good people quickly then it's so that
we do a paidad or something like that
and say  hey we're looking for
new bakers here in Heidelberg, um that's it,
but for the most part we haven't
invested much in marketing so far,
so it's easy back then, um our
founders
came up with a very good concept, um I think you
can say very, very clearly how
They sew, especially for that
time, now there are
similarly good
bakery concepts in all cities, back then it was
unheard of, um and er, and they simply
created this shopping experience with
the glass bakery where you
can really look inside with a
cool design of the shops and  That
just pulled, say so in the end it's
location, we learned it at Apple
and the Apple Stores are Irish, so to
speak, marketing so your locations are
many will have never been in one before,
listen here now,
I can't
imagine that right now  glass bakery what
else is part of your stor concept
so is that how do you do it
especially so I you can't even
say that we are in cool locations per se
in total inner city locations
we are also partly in locations on old
Schönhauserstrasse in Berlin now  Here
in Hamburg Ottensen Ottenser Hauptstrasse
they have come gradually, we
simply have a clientele where we said
hey, that could work, what does
the store do? The store itself is
relatively reserved in design,
I would say, so you have a warm
and inviting atmosphere, of
course  Because the bakery
is open right there with a
glass pane and in the passageway where
the connection
between production and sales is,
you have the smells that come out and
and honestly there isn't much more,
so that means there are  Now
not somehow the crazy store
concept where then somehow so special
colors or special so we have we
have certain design elements that we are
currently actively
questioning and also
question again and again you have
you don't have a standard
chain store design like we do  our how
we do our shops but
now we're talking about furniture we're talking
about tiles so we're trying to create a
natural inviting atmosphere
that puts the bakery so the heart of every
shop this glass bakery in the
center of attention it has to
be glass that's
that's such a  big peephole into
the wstube yes, you're right, I'm
assuming that everyone knows our stores,
but in fact what defines our store
is, first and foremost,
a bread shelf, which every bakery
has, and a counter, which every bakery also
has  a glass bakery,
which means you come in and the
first thing you notice is at best
and that's how the shops are designed
with the bakery in mind and it's really
a full production behind glass, yes
behind glass for hygiene reasons,
logically not okay and therefore not
so much flour dust in them  Sales room
blows and I mean well, how much does it cost to set
up a fake Inal when you
say for the first time now you have
found a standard until it
is online, so to speak, until it works
then somehow you have to put in a million first,
yes we are
now actually  Even with
construction costs that have increased significantly in the last
two years,
we are actually at one to 1.5 million.
Wow for a new location for
a new
location. Invest has now
given you money again to really
grow or  Yes, we
actually manage to finance this from the
current business, but that's
why we would
n't be able to manage more than three or four stores a year,
but let's say
the logical business economist thinks that's okay if
the
branch is profitable in Z D
So if you put 1.5 years
into it and then you need that
many years, we've just calculated
maybe a few more until it's
break-even then you can,
so to speak, immediately scale it up and say
now we'll do it in a
year somehow  times 30 branches because the
playbook is there, the playbook is
actually there, so what you are basically
talking about is of course also what
makes us strong and what is also, um, what
is also a knowledge, a know-how, an
ability to know what we are about  In recent
years, especially with
specialists, we have an architect in the
team, an interior designer and so on, um
what we have acquired, we have built up,
um, but of course it is like that. We
spoke earlier about the topic of
personnel, um we talked about raw materials, raw
material chains and so on  It's
not that we
could open 30 stores, it's possible that we'll
have this power at some point,
but at the moment we're a medium-sized company,
so that would be hugely overwhelming for me
today, and for the company
anyway, so no, we wouldn't be able to
do it, I think  Um,
we wouldn't be able to find that many bakers these days.
I believe that if we continue to
expand as well as we are currently
doing, we will of course be working
intensively on this, as we talked about, but
trainees, that we are
setting up an academy ourselves, so to speak, that we are developing people and
bringing in managers  and so on then it can
get there at some point 30 I
already think I think it's crazy
okay the concept is too
complicated for that that's like I said a
full production that and so what
allows you to
get away from this meat trend of bakery eggs in the end
because we can  overread
Bakeries are dying anyway and you say
it's not like that in certain locations and
we only go to the locations or
in certain quality levels it's not something like that,
which takes you away from this trend
so I think that I'm just a
little bit crazy about wheat  Trend
you have two two two extremes at one
end are us or, thank
God, there are now even concepts on the market
that are even more brotic,
so I always say that's then
you somehow have a counter there are
three loaves of bread on marble  and when the three
loaves of bread are sold I exaggerate it a
bit, but then the
shop closes for the day and it's very classy
so juelier the baker juelier that's exactly what it
is and I also think it's really
great that it exists  In
principle everything is
again, these are bakers who have
rediscovered the topic
in this premium level and it
is really fantastic bread, really
great quality,
there is more and more popping up, I'll say
not everywhere but in the larger
cities and I find it  I think it's a really
great development because it's important
that people learn again that
good bread
makes a huge difference
m like that and that's
one end and at the other
end you have, I'd say, the
discount baker, the one who is basically the blank
dough pieces just in
Quotes baked on um tkbare
in all as a rule um and and
exactly like that and in between you have a
lot
we are somewhere in between no we are
not a broutik because we
actually have from 8 a.m. to 6 p.m. 1920 exactly
we have from 8 a.m. to 6 p.m. 1920
open every day we have a relatively
wide range compared to these
yes the word brtik is then
really something that I also like to use
that is also this this extremely m and
then you have, I would say, classic
branch bakeries that are certainly there
too  huge differences from one who is
more involved in the industry, who
produces very large quantities industrially,
who dies, so what kind of chip, right
now I think that everyone
is in between who doesn't
focus either in one
direction or in the other direction, that
is  Everyone who is somewhere too
small is stuck in the middle, exactly
who are perhaps too small
to either concentrate
on the very noble direction in terms of personnel know-how and to
make very, very high-quality things and therefore also have a solid
customer base, so do I
say at the locations where you
have enough frequency and so on and
on the other or which then
basically say hey I'm here I'm here
on price and and
quantity and can do it
efficiently and profitably
those in between are stuck  in the
middle as you rightly say, these are the ones
that I think have difficulties in many places. They
would also go to these prepayment
areas in supermarkets and so on
that an important sales pillar
for us is also this B2B business, which
accounts for almost 30% of our sales.
In fact, the idea of ​​a
naturouras and and and but would be to
go in the pre-box area
if you know it like that, you wouldn't
do it there yourself  Open a location
that doesn't correspond to our concept,
our concept is really in our
own stores at our own
locations that are manufactured on site, we
understood and S such a quick one,
it works well, so I mean you are
now a supplier, a lot of that is bought
by the quick ones and yes  That's
basically working well,
so I mean during
Corona they all went through the roof,
the qcers companies um that's when
we went in there for the first time
and grew a lot with the area um
now it's weakened a bit
basically I think
That won't be a secret
now, the people at flink wo
n't turn their necks when I
say it like that, but I believe that this channel
is justified and you have customers for different products like
any other in any other
shopping location
Even at Flink there are
customers who just
want to buy a bread loaf that is somehow pre-cut and sealed in plastic, but there are also customers who are looking
for very high quality from very
good raw materials
My grain exports from
Ukraine, I somehow read, were
of course problematic last year because of the war, it affected you,
um, it definitely affected us,
but only indirectly, so it's true
that people say that
Ukraine
is the granary of Europe, but of course that is  no
biolandware, so the
organic land certification Bioland means
that it basically comes from Germany,
um, that means our raw materials
basically come from Germany, but
now of course it is the case when a
huge relevant source of raw materials
disappears on the world market or on the
German market, um, then of
course they increase  The
raw material prices in all areas, which also means for us,
we also have to raise prices
and so on. The
prices of raw materials have risen, but
due to this organic and
organic land issue,
it is still relatively limited in comparison. It was already
relatively high in price before, which is
why bi-products are also more expensive  than
other products, that's no
secret,
but it's the case that it
has an indirect impact and not as
bad as conventional bakers, i.e.
the non-organic inflation in general, so
people are no longer there as buying clients
because inflation simply takes
money out of people's pockets
So I can, of course I
can't measure it. So far we're growing well
on existing space, so now
apart from the new openings,
I think that people
are becoming more and more sensitive to the topic.
I would say that I think my bread can
now be described as a luxury good
I find it difficult and,
as I said, I don't see us as a luxury bakery at all
because we simply produce very, very good,
high-quality goods, but that
simply depends on how much
value people place on it, now
individually, everyone has to
decide for themselves what they want  If
we want to spend money we definitely notice that there is
inflation um we notice it um in terms of
wages too so um now
we had a minimum wage increase um last
year in the fall now the next
minimum wage increase is coming um
I don't think it has been officially finalized yet
but it is  The next one is coming in
January, um we can assume that and
um we're not just paying anyone the
minimum wage now but it's like that
and that doesn't just affect us in
production but it also affects the
entire catering industry to which we also
belong um that um  the total wages
increase accordingly and that is
definitely an
inflation driver for us because, for example, an
inflation compensation or something like that, which of
course we would also like to pay,
we can't pay at the moment, what about
internationalization for you,
so something like that to London Paris
Amsterdam I  I don't know
any others, for you it's
probably Germany first
and then another one downstream, no,
we actually opened
the first international location three months ago,
um, and now the
big thing is coming
in Tel Aviv in Israel, so it
's actually right now
Also, first of all, it's basically
you can say um that was a total
coincidence um it was sometime about 3 years ago
a very nice couple from
Tel Aviv came to our store in Berlin um and
asked if we could
somehow do something together  want to do and
we actually did a join ventcher
with them we own
the majority um and yes three months ago we
opened a shop in Tel Aviv
beautiful shop
Tel Aviv is an incredible foodi
city so there are a lot of people who also
value good food  lay and
high value food and um and um it's
also got off to an incredibly good start and it's been
incredibly well received um yes the
people there I think all over the
world we have a right to exist
because German
bread if I hear that then it would make my
fingers itch to say that it does  I
now have to wait so long in Paris and Amsterdam to
finance it from the cash loss. I mean, yes, I
understand that you can do that, but
you would have to really step on the
gas and say okay,
the Americans have McDonald's and we
have time  for bread now we're on the gas yes
with McDonald's I wouldn't like to compare us
so yes yes yes the complexity is
much higher, of course we're
actually dealing with it
now without an incredibly huge
strategy behind it
because it's complicated and you have to
find a partner locally  You have to
find skilled workers who
can actually implement it and so on,
but we are actually looking into where
we
can expand internationally. The focus is
clearly on Germany, but I'm kind of a
Dutch guy now, he
can get in touch and say  h too I'm
backffin and B now vi not a baker
necessarily but I have to
mark it here as advertising Advertising on my
own behalf so if someone would
like to load themselves with a time for bread and
also want to invest so it
also shows the commitment be it in
Great Britain in France or in
Holland approaches us then we would
examine it very carefully and would be very
happy to start discussions, of course,
but in Israel it was more of a
coincidence and now the current situation
is of course also a setback for the time being,
I think  Little said no, so it's
of course a very challenging
situation right now, even three months
after the opening, we're still
in the challenge that you
always have after an opening, no with
training and so on, but yes,
clearly internationally, it's still exciting
and is up  our agenda and also
relatively high on the strategic
agenda but if you don't
want to grow so quickly from the cash flow
then I have
had many guests here in the last few years who are with
franchise systems, no, it's
not conceivable for you, no it's for us  It's not
conceivable that we actually
tried that once, but that was before my
time, so I can't
say too much about it. There was
a franchise partner in Cologne, that
then fell apart, that didn't
work so well, which is what you do again and
again and I  I can only emphasize it again and again
that we are a
super complicated product driven by super skilled workers
and um and that really requires
a lot of know-how in every
direction, be it structural, be it
technical,
be it basic operation, who are they?
There are some
baking kings in Germany who have become
really comfortable with bakeries in the last few decades.
I think of Mr.
Kams with his Kamamps
bakeries. I think he
really got rich with that, but
then he stopped
baking everywhere and that was it  Well,
honestly, I don't know the production
that's behind it in detail,
but it produces
centrally in central production facilities
and supplies sales branches, but it's
the biggest thing in Germany. I do
n't know that, I
actually know that, so that's a market like that  No,
to be honest, I
of course we look at competitors, but these are
more like the classic organic bakers
that are on site in the respective
regions,
these are the brtiken as I
mentioned before, the very, very
high-quality bakers, these classic
branch bakers, the same  are totally good,
I'll say in Cologne you can't get
past Märzen, in Munich you ca
n't get past Richard, but these are
different concepts than we are, they
are certainly also good bakers but a
conventional, usually not
organic and and B those  They
have a central production somewhere or
maybe one or two or three,
I don't know, and supply their
sales outlets is a different concept
and there are from to I think
Richard in Munich has 13 branches,
that's not a lot, there are some with 40
Branches with 80 branches, I think
Kams will have well over 100, I do
n't know, a few hundred, maybe
I'm honestly not that deep
into the industry because we really
do our own thing here, which means our competitors are
more like them  Classic
organic bakers who also operate on a smaller scale in the
respective regions or
these very high-quality boutiques, but whatever else
you know, I also had
Royal Donuts or something like that as a
guest on the podcast a while ago, which also comes a lot
from the online world, so to speak
I have generated an interest in their donut
yes
locations you don't do that so you I
've now looked on Instagram I
think you're 40,000 or something like that
yes so our goal was
by the end of the year show GZ it shows that
's not the case now  so that you
use elements online offline somehow or there
now or do you use bug influencers or
something like that od or no not at all
honestly not so we are
currently still leaving and I say never say never
no but we are currently simply using
our products and our employees
who speak for themselves so if you
look at our Instagram account then
we really try to put the people in
the foreground so the employees who
produce because we live from them so
you can replace me tomorrow
I'm I'm just a manager
but they're the ones  Craftsmen who
produce this great product on site
just make a huge difference
and you can't even get it
recreated quickly and K will
soon have some robots or something like that
that together just not just not no
in no way no so
then  then time for bread is dead
so the concept thrives on good craftsmanship
but it could also be that a branch
like this behind a window like this has
robot arms that do it so completely professionally,
I mean you can even
have cars built completely by Elon Musk in the gigafactories these days but
you also say no would also so
there it goes into great
detail about the production in the
bakery but that
so central production
you have machines that then
the dough is tipped in at the top and then there are
portioners and  so on, um,
and then there are different things, from a
robot that does everything to a
mixture of, um, weighing portioners
and then maybe the final
knife cut from the
baker's employee, um but as a rule, the
dough we make isn't made
by machines at all  processable, so we
have, for example, in our house bread we have
such a high water content, it's like
a pudding that
I can't manage
to shape the thing at all and I've been
with the company for four years now, I have it
now  To be honest, I don't try it every day,
but I always try to
somehow get the bread to look so nice and
round and the thing
flows every time and it tears
and because that because the ma no you do
n't make a plan what machine can do that
these days no no  I don't think so,
I don't think so, but every now and then
you bake along or are you say
I would say I would
n't go that far that I really bake along
but to get into it and understand what's
happening absolutely, of course, so we are,
we are now 600  with
people working almost in Germany it's very
labor-intensive about the shops and
also the shift work and so
on but we're
very very flat and
I'm in the bakery somewhere almost every day
and take a quick look and
I'm not a baker I would  that and
should never say that because they
can do a lot more than me
but um but of course I'm trying to
see how it
works, so I just want to
understand it, no, I think that's what you should do
as a manager. There are
role models for this in the USA or something like that  So like that or
in other countries somehow no,
I would even say that we, um, there
are, I just said
there are the broutiks, there are also
concepts like us in other countries, of
course there are great bakeries but as far as
I know, none  to scale this up
to the level of quality
as well as we do, so
with the 13 stores I think we are
the largest in the world. Now I have to be very
careful. Of course I have
n't researched it completely, but of course I
get a bit of it
what's happening on the market but in
terms of quality,
I'll say the largest bakery chain in
quotation marks, um in the world.
I would think that
the prices for
shop rent are at least just about suitable for you, so it's
noticeable that there are now somehow
other potential tenants  If we
get problems or are no longer there,
then the owners say okay, we're going
down a little bit with the rental prices,
so to be honest, in the locations where we
want to go, the competition is
still there and of course we want to go
to central inner city locations, we
need large areas  because of the
full production because of the
storage capacity we need and so on um
no so unfortunately unfortunately
there isn't much movement on the market yet
or thank God no so I'm a
big advocate of the city centers and
the retail of the stationary
retail
um but of course we we we  Um,
of course, we also compete with the
big clothing chains, um, then for
these locations, some of them um and yes, they
also have the money
to pay the rent, so that we can manage it as a bakery,
which is of course possible
for a while because of our scaling
You're actually creating a lot of value right
now with your team,
so if you assume that you
'll achieve 100 million in sales in a few years
and then maybe now
we've barely beaten it because not
even 30 million in results, what's
something like that worth?  what are the multipl
so is it then looked at somehow it's
not a softwarefma but it's
ten times the result then you've created 300
million in sales 3 million in goodwill
or or or how do
you currently look at it so
in the so like you like you  That's right, the
private equity world will
of course look at multiple things at some point,
how high will they be for us at
some point or not? You
would have to ask the
questions, yes, I would think that a
high-quality, I'll say now in
quotation marks, food concept like
ours might be 8  up to ze maybe
even reach 12 multiples, yes I would
think that could be achieved and what that
one day maybe 300
million in goodwill can be created,
yes now we have to wait and see, so
currently we are trying to keep our 13
stores running somehow um
and and  That's where I am then I'm
more in the here and now,
honestly, but clearly I believe that
we create value and um my focus is
actually and it sounds
a bit naive now or or um or um yes
so my focus is simply um
this craft  to celebrate and to
create jobs and
to teach people that good bread
simply makes a huge difference
and is healthy, good bread because bread
per se is actually very
strong now g I'll take a look at
some nutritional influencers say
pond and so on  Actually, everything is
n't really healthy per se. It
should actually just be
kind of good, I don't know vegetables and fish
and so on. So I would strongly
disagree, I think it
makes a huge difference which bread you
have when it's time for bread
I'm happy to admit that I
only then completely switched to
high-quality bread like we make
and I noticed this in the
digestion, so you notice that because what
I just said
machines when as soon as you somehow
have machines in the production process
you are  forced
recipes or processes and so on, for
example, and that's the big topic, that's
the topic of gluten, which is
artificially added to the dough because you have
more gluten is a glue, a
natural enzyme in the flour, which is then
artificially added to everything  Rule
and this also happens in most
conventional and, above all,
industrial manufacturing companies
and at that moment you
gradually have this issue of gluten intolerance
or
gluten intolerance
and if you leave that out you simply have
better
tolerance in general, say it is
healthy but it is  not really a
healthy lifestyle is not eating bread
or at least I would
say yes, like with everything
it's always a question of what you
eat, of course, although I would say even
if you eat wheat bread it's in
the evening, for example  Maybe it's
also so it's easier to digest than,
for example, a wholemeal bread because
the grains have to be digested first when you have them in the evening,
so wholemeal is
not
as easy to digest at all times of the day, which
means I would maybe in the evening
too  eat a wheat spelled mixed bread
somehow or something like that but
basically bread is absolutely a
healthy food of course okay okay okay
so at some point it's
philosophical and there are a lot of
opinions from could be influencers and I do
n't know health influencers something else
or experts maybe
hopefully so
In any case, I now
understand what he's doing and so I
can classify it better now and
the next time I
walk past Finale I won't think. Yes,
I definitely wish you much
success and I'll like it if
a German concept like that
I
think it would really work internationally, so bread is a
product that Germany has a competence
for and that's why there
might be more in it
than you're
letting on right now, I mean, Israel has
shown that the store is working  through the
roof, it's going extremely well, as I said,
right now you can maybe
leave a little bit of food in, you have to
leave food in, but basically
it's very well accepted, of course, I
believe that we can function everywhere
Israel is the proof, um, I
have some of it myself in Great Britain  I
studied, um, I
drove half an hour to the nearest Lidl,
which is also there because they had
pumpernickel and I bought it for myself. Anyone
who has ever lived in the USA or
actually no matter where abroad as a
German
misses what most people do without  Is bread a good German
bread or good bread in principle and that's
why I believe that we
can work everywhere, so of
course you're right, I think we can
work anywhere internationally and
we're dealing with that, as I said,
but the focus is on
healthy growth with a good one
Product that we also have to keep, so we
often have to here in the podcast you are open
for business, we have already said who is
now traveling abroad here, we also
try to create networks here, so to speak,
not just pure
listening pleasure but also a bit of
feedback or inspiration  for those
listening who says okay, I feel like
doing something like that somewhere in Holland or Poland or, I don't know, Italy, okay Stefan Heinrich is ready,
I think I had you on
the left, I even know how it went,
so in any case you're available  We are
also welcome to make contact, I would be
happy to do so if desired,
thank you very much and all the best, thank you for
the invitation yes thank you ciao ciao
[music]
bye